I am arundathi Gupta I'm a global shaper
in the Bangla hub and I run an
organization in bangalore called mentor
together which is a non-profit nonprofit
this is the first West that I am
attending and I've enjoyed it thoroughly
until now the global shapers had a
meeting before this which was extremely
useful to get to know what everyone's
doing as well as to interact with some
of the weijl community which can be
great mentorship for global leaders I
absolutely enjoyed the sessions that I
attended today I really like the session
in the morning on South Asian children I
got a chance to speak myself in the
session on the vision for Indian and
that was also a great opportunity to
share some of the work and to hear from
other participants about what they liked
I like the session on the shaker Gupta
led though I thought it was sometimes a
little too confrontational but I guess
that's just the nature of the game it
was highly entertaining and the comments
that the professor from Harvard made
work great